last week I asked you leave your entries
in the sir really close and now I should
maybe show the next episode of why yes
another week it's another why such a
great name just rolls off the tongue
love why that's H the best show on
internet last week it was so popular we
got on trending let's see what means you
posted last week love wine you know I
usually challenge you guys hey do this
hey wouldn't it be cool if we we do a
theme this week but no it's always just
means Jess Manik means just memes and
I'm always the end of the joke it's like
a collectible people throwing [ __ ] at me
and I have to deflect left and right oh
yes I have original ideas there are some
good videos no my channel isn't
washed-up it still gets millions abuse
yeah oh oh so so you can you can't
afford paying $300 for a chair and I've
completely lost touch with reality that
that's not typically the amount that you
would pay but can you do this oh great
oh look at that
it's a repost of me reposting a repost
congratulations if Felix such stop
reposting my tweets and why'd he repulse
our memes
can't be the most hated person on the
Internet if there is no internet YouTube
rewind was [ __ ] guess who did not get
featured on YouTube reoww
it's not funny okay let's go scrap today
Florida what it means you are the love
of my life in Swedish ah that's right
y'all just throw share my direction I'm
helping you get laid with such wonderful
new language that I'm teaching you I am
inviting you to the world of Swiss Jian
Scaletta to Florida it will make any
[ __ ] drip like Niagara Falls Christian
channel remember boo this is her now
feel old yet no you know that looks like
shitty new trailer that everyone's
posting about hey that's her now clearly
thanks to me yeah do I have to make the
memes for you now is that what this has
come to learn how to learn how to bleep
and mean if you're gonna post on my
reddit do you think this is some sort of
joke no title needed buddy if you're
good at something never do it for free
stolen means I think I make five bucks
from these haters YouTube demonisation
domani ty station media P deep I read it
yeah can you add another frame to this
we're read it puts a dagger in my back
how about that then it's accurate then I
will give it a lot
pewds in high school our y equals Lin C
squared e plus Lin and I divided with V
our y equals ln c squared e c r AC i
don't know the english terminology
you're all you're always so up in my ass
about things like I said they a to be
two squared and in Sweden would say a to
equal our okay o4 means
squared so it's this just shut up
it's what I'm trying to tell you and
that becomes e ry when you remove the
line' which becomes c e ni b which
becomes their death the V times e raised
to ry okay very it becomes very nice now
this is man this is why I've dropped out
of high school which I did it I
university I dropped that a university
ok I'm not some sort of pleb that didn't
make it through high school who drops
out at the high school when I say very
net very nice it's not just me having
the lack of better word and repeating
myself constantly because I'm not smart
enough
it's me challenging you guys with
complex mathematical equations to see
are you paying attention if I easily
saying very nice or very nice it's a
it's a black and white difference and
you can't argue against it I'm putting
way too much emphasis into one single
image and we have a lot to go through so
let's keep going tables have turned
ok that was like I was a good good
example of a reverse petting dog meme
well done
I created a reddit account just to
submit this ok well then it has to be
good I will be aborted I'm not even
gonna finish it
rewind 2017 raise that finger doggie
there you go that's that's how you do
the image inspiring quotes by famous
people
a man is but the project of his thought
thoughts what he thinks he becomes
education is the most powerful weapon
which you can use to change the world by
mightier yes yes it is sold a 399 and
I'll have you let you know but can you
do this
I don't think so am i doing this right
that's a pretty good Photoshop I got it
well done good job oh it's a Doki Doki
mean watching peers play Doki Doki
pretty accurate I must say got what do
you want and hey look at that told you I
told you I could have held their hands
good me good me well done well done I
see no difference oh my god
actually yeah what the heck one doesn't
have a pedo beard damn it can I the real
reason why pip I wasn't in YouTube
rewind it's because the video was in ten
minutes yeah why did they not make it
ten minutes no they know they can just
make the outro three minutes longer and
then they get three times the revenue
imagine if you had me work and you have
to do a specific amount of work but you
could get three times more for that work
if you happen to make the video ten
minutes long when pewds has died like
five thousand times but it's still zero
Depp's told you guys I challenge you
intellectually and I'm glad that you're
thinking when it's January and your
shirt for shadows the future I remember
wearing that in January I foreshadowed
the future okay I wore that thinking yes
this is actually to even set in videos
2017 is the year where it's all gonna go
down for me because I knew the media
where the media was going with it
okay I'm not stupid low-effort memes
guys literally only want one thing and
it's effing disgusting original content
good job
what happened listen this hair this hair
I [ __ ] rock it okay you wish you wish
you can have this hair get it to
trending come on I haven't seen a single
one of my videos get to trending in 84
years 2017 - 84 is 1933 federal election
were held in Germany in 1933 Adolf
Hitler hi PewDiePie hi
coincidence I think not spawn first very
nice on the Christian Channel very nice
oh sure
will you don't let your love
okay okay everybody that was this week's
of Lavoie rolls right off the tongue
beautiful well done you know what for
for once I will only say this once
ever good job you did a good job very
nice this week was very nice well done
remember to leave a like and watch this
video multiple times so we can get it on
trending share it subscribe but also
square